next question is from Tommy Tommy says
hey guys are their warnings on products
or services or activities that you
routinely ignore ok here's a few that I
have number one license agreements for
software I mean I'm agreeing to it I
don't know if I'm ignoring it or not I
have no idea what the hell is in there
so sort of by default I guess I kind of
em ignoring it we're not gonna go
through ten pages of of language that
you don't even really understand for the
most part it was interesting too is
they've put in prize prizes in that text
all ripple will will end up claiming
like a thousand or two thousand dollars
just because they read the terms and
services of the agreement hi that's
that's fascinating there must be so few
people that read it that they know
they're not gonna put too much money at
stake mattress warning labels I don't
know that the mattress warning labels
actually warned you about usage of the
mattress I think they just say you're
not allowed to remove the label unless
you're the consumer or something like
that that's fine but I've used many
mattresses in my life and I've never
once read what the hell those warning
label say and I've never had an interest
in taking off the label to it never
really seemed necessary but you have to
wonder what the penalty is for doing
such a thing if it's done not by the
consumer yeah that is a really good
question at restaurants when they bring
place and they say the top plate is hot
I'm kind of careful but I do touch it
every time I have this genuine curiosity
about how hot that top plate is I don't
know if that happens to you yeah maybe
they're just being overwhelmingly leak
heat sensitive or something in the low
fuel light on my car I don't ignore it
forever but I do like to see how far I
can take it and I don't go dangerously
far like after it's the it might my fuel
light is basically eight lines each
corresponding to a 12 an eighth of the
tank and the the first seven or white
and the last one is red so you get down
and you have just one red line left and
then the red line starts blinking and
once the red line starts blinking I
assume I'm pretty low and it's time to
get gas yeah I always wait until the
light comes on to and I always set the
trip odometer thing so I know how many
more miles I can really go but I won't
push it past 10 miles especially to get
stuck in traffic oh here yeah and also
if there's a snow situation that happens
they like that and that relates to
another one thunderstorm warnings I know
that in the South it's different but in
Massachusetts I I basically ignore
thunderstorm warnings I do whatever I
need to do now tornado warnings are
another story and we've actually had a
couple tornadoes touch down in
Massachusetts in the last five or six
years but in Massachusetts I've never
found that uh I've I've been at risk by
ignoring thunderstorm warnings and
lastly i unplug USB cables from the
computer without making sure that it's
safe to do so and I've never had a
problem you live life on the edge those
are the real ones that I uh that I can
think of send me some thoughts if you
have